estas son las noticias de france 24
avanza en españa el debate en el consejo
de ministros que determinará si aprueba
o no el pedido de indulto hecho por el
presidente del gobierno pedro sánchez a
los nueve políticos independentistas
catalanes que están en prisión por los
delitos de malversación y sedición en
minutos les contamos quiénes son tenemos
los detalles
continúa la oleada de represión contra
opositores en nicaragua la policía
detuvo a la política opositora maría
fernanda flores también el periodista
miguel mendoza y allanó la casa del
periodista carlos fernando chamorro ya
son 17 los políticos detenidos cinco de
ellos precandidatos presidenciales
países como méxico y argentina
rechazaron estas detenciones
y un juez peruano declaró como infundado
el pedido de la fiscalía para que la
candidata presidencial del partido
fuerza popular keiko fujimori retorne a
prisión por estar relacionada con el
escándalo de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht fujimori es señalada de
haberse reunido con testigos claves del
caso les contamos en minutos
muy buenos días estamos en vivo desde
los estudios de france 24 en bogotá en
colombia soy santiago lópez gonzález
gracias por acompañarnos hasta ahora
vamos a comenzar en españa en europa en
donde a esta hora avanza el consejo de
ministros- del que en el que se debate
sobre los posibles indultos para que los
nueve políticos independentistas
catalanes encarcelados desde 2017 y que
fueron condenados en 2019 a penas entre
9 y 13 años de prisión por malversación
y sedición la propuesta hecha por el
presidente del gobierno pedro sánchez
choca con la bancada de derecha y
también de la ultraderecha española
presente en el parlamento pero el
gobierno lo defiende como la única vía
para recuperar la concordia con la
comunidad autónoma de cataluña esto a
pesar de que ninguno de los encarcelados
ha declarado arrepentimiento por los
hechos ocurridos a continuación les
contamos quiénes son estos líderes
independentistas que podrían salir de
prisión en los próximos días eso es lo
que el gobierno de españa ha decidido la
decisión simbólicamente más compleja del
mandato de pedro sánchez frontal
a los nueve líderes independentistas
encarcelados tras el referéndum
unilateral de independencia de cataluña
de 2017 ingresaron en prisión
provisional vamos a iniciar nuevas
sesiones del juicio oral en febrero de
2019 arrancaron tres meses de juicio
durante el cual ninguno de los
procesados expresó arrepentimiento
finalmente el 14 de octubre del mismo
año el tribunal supremo emitió las
sentencias condenatorias por delitos de
malversación y sedición resolución que
incendió las calles de barcelona oriol
junqueras quien era vicepresidente
catalán fue condenado a 13 años de
prisión creo sinceramente que lo mejor
para todos sería devolver la cuestión al
terreno de la política de la buena
política
jordi turull que ocupaba el cargo de
consejero de la presidencia raúl romeva
consejero de exteriores y dolors bassa
consejera de asuntos sociales fueron
condenados a 12 años de prisión la ex
presidenta del parlamento catalán
carme forcadell fue sentenciada a 11
años y seis meses de prisión también se
condenó a diez años y seis meses de
prisión a los ex consejeros de interior
y de territorios joaquim forn y sus
todos fueron inhabilitados para ejercer
cargos públicos en la misma causa fueron
procesados y condenados los activistas
jordi sánchez y jordi kuhs art cuyas
penas de nueve años de prisión han sido
las más señaladas por organizaciones
internacionales al no ocupar cargos
públicos en el momento de los hechos
sino la dirección de organizaciones de
la sociedad civil
la medida no aplica el entonces
presidente catalán carles puigdemont que
sigue exiliado en bélgica y no ha sido
juzgado por la justicia española que
cataluña los de bing y uno está quinto
ponen en forma de república los indultos
abren una nueva etapa de diálogo entre
madrid y barcelona pero no resuelven las
demandas de autodeterminación del pueblo
catalán y por otro lado plantean la
incógnita sobre la futura hoja de ruta
del movimiento independentista que desde
2017 ha reclamado libertad para los que
considera prisioneros políticos
hablamos ahora de nicaragua ya son 17
los políticos opositores arrestados en
ese país centroamericano cinco de ellos
precandidatos presidenciales que
buscaban participar en las elecciones
del 7 de noviembre recientemente fueron
detenidos la política opositora maría
fernanda flores también el periodista
miguel mendoza y también fue allanada la
casa del periodista carlos fernando
chamorro las acciones han provocado todo
tipo de críticas sobre el presidente
nicaragüense daniel ortega que también
busca un tercer mandato en esos mismos
comicios países como méjico y argentina
rechazaron estas detenciones pese a que
la semana pasada se habían abstenido en
la votación de una resolución de condena
por parte de la organización de estados
américanos oea
alva santana nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
a menos de 5 meses de las elecciones ya
son 5 los precandidatos a la presidencia
bajo arresto en nicaragua algo que desde
la oposición califican como una
persecución política que lleva en marcha
en los últimos tres años el régimen ha
estado secuestrando a personas durante
los últimos tres años lo que pasa que en
estas últimas tres semanas lo que ha
hecho el régimen es que ha secuestrado a
los candidatos y candidatas que son a la
presidencia el periodista miguel mora es
el más reciente fue detenido por atentar
contra la soberanía nacional junto a
arturo cruz sebastián chamorro félix
maradiaga y cristiana chamorro la
principal rival de daniel ortega y quien
podría hacer peligrar la tercera
reelección del sandinista hay un gran
temor de la salud y la condición física
mental y psicológica de estos candidatos
hay candidatos que tienen problemas de
presión arterial que tienen diabetes que
tienen otras índoles y no sabemos bajo
qué condiciones está porque el régimen
no permite que se vean a los
precandidatos además en
y una polémica ley que el ejecutivo
aprobó en diciembre del 2020 también han
sido detenidos otros líderes opositores
como ex cancilleres ex guerrilleros
empresarios y activistas hechos
condenados por la comunidad
internacional y por lo que argentina y
méjico llamaron a consultas a sus
respectivos embajadores no obstante
ambas naciones siguen apostando por la
no intervención en asuntos internos
razón por la que se abstuvieron de votar
en la resolución de la oea contra las
acciones del gobierno de ortega
aquí con nosotros también en medio de la
incertidumbre acerca de los resultados
de las elecciones presidenciales en perú
que aún no tienen un pronunciamiento por
parte de la autoridad electoral un juez
declaró como infundado el pedido de la
fiscalía para que la candidata del
partido fuerza popular keiko fujimori
retorne a prisión por un caso de lavado
que está relacionado con el escándalo de
la constructora brasileña odebrecht esto
tras haber sido acusada por incumplir
con las restricciones como reunirse con
algunos de los testigos clave del caso
keiko fujimori seguirá en libertad el
juez peruano víctor su única determinó
que la candidata presidencial no
devolverá la cárcel por el caso de la
constructora brasileña odebrecht el
requerimiento al ministerio público del
riesgo de que se revoque la comparación
y hago restricciones y se dicte
nuevamente de prisión preventiva contra
la acusada tengo fujimori el fiscal
asegura que fujimori es la jefa de un
grupo de crimen organizado lavado de
activos obstrucción a la justicia y
declarar falsamente en medio un
procedimiento administrativo por lo que
pedía 30 años de prisión para ella y 22
para su esposo
[Música]
el conteo de motos en el medio de una
para nuestro país varios de sus
seguidores manifestaron su apoyo al
desacuerdo a washington
la sesión se dio en medio en perú
polarizado que aún no conoce quién será
su próximo presidente el candidato
izquierdista pedro castillo tiene cerca
de 44 mil votos de ventaja sobre
conmemora pero aún no ha sido ratificado
como el ganador por el jurado nacional
de elecciones que continúa resolviendo
las apelaciones de las actas observadas
y los pedidos de nulidad presentados
después de las elecciones del 6 de junio
cambiamos de continente las autoridades
de sudáfrica dieron a conocer su avance
en la primera etapa para producir
vacunas contra el kobe 19 en su
territorio el proyecto busca suministrar
al continente africano una mejor
capacidad de difusión del medicamento
apenas el 2% de la población africana ha
recibido al menos una dosis de alguna de
las vacunas contra el cob y 19 y tanto
los planes de vacunación como el
suministro de dosis a través del
mecanismo kóvacs avanzan lentamente
vacunar a los sudafricanos con dosis
fabricadas en su propio territorio esa
es la ambición del gobierno de cyril
ramaphosa las autoridades con el apoyo
de la oms se quieren establecer un
centro de transferencia de tecnología
para las vacunas de aire en el mensajero
antich hoy sería el primero de este tipo
en suelo africano estos centros de
transferencia de tecnología son lugares
de capacitación donde los fabricantes de
países de ingresos bajos y medios pueden
recibir capacitación sobre cómo producir
ciertas vacunas y las licencias
correspondientes para hacerlo en la
actualidad sólo el 2% de la población
africana ha recibido al menos una dosis
de una vacuna contra el coronavirus
mientras que eeuu y europa se acercan al
50% sudáfrica también representa más del
35 por ciento de los casos registrados
de ccoo y 19 en áfrica mientras que las
dosis prometidas por el programa kóvacs
están disminuyendo
en boxing simplemente no podemos seguir
dependiendo de las vacunas fabricadas
fuera de áfrica porque nunca llegan
nunca llegan a tiempo y la gente sigue
muriendo por eso pedimos el
levantamiento de la patente pero también
la transferencia de tecnología esto
sería un paso increíble desde fenómenos
ramaphosa ha hecho campaña activamente
para el levantamiento atemporal de las
patentes de las vacunas y se ha
convertido en un duro crítico de la
desigualdad en el acceso a ellas si todo
va según lo planeado
sudáfrica podría fabricar vacunas en un
plazo de 9 a 12 meses según la ms y los
etíopes acudieron a las urnas este lunes
en lo que ha sido descrito por el primer
ministro había cnet como las primeras
elecciones libres y justas en esa nación
africana debido a la alta afluencia de
votantes la junta nacional electoral
decidió extender la jornada por tres
horas más para que los ciudadanos
pudieran ejercer su derecho al voto
la jornada electoral llega después de
haber sido pospuesta varias veces debido
a la pandemia de kobe 19 y también por
los retos logísticos por la seguridad en
algunas regiones los ojos de la
comunidad internacional están sobre este
país africano donde
el conflicto en la región de tigre y no
permitió que todas las circunscripciones
organizaran los comicios es por este
motivo que 60 escaños de la cámara baja
van a quedar vacantes hasta tanto no
sean realizados allí los comicios en
esas regiones que no han podido realizar
las votaciones
y hablamos ahora de deportes en los
juegos olímpicos de tokio van a contar
con cinco nuevas disciplinas entre ellas
está el skateboarding indie dãaz es
brasileña tiene 23 años y va a
representar a su país en esta nueva
disciplina para su preparación indie da
cuenta con una pista de entrenamiento
propia en su casa en donde se prepara
para realizar en tokio una vuelta
perfecta en sólo 45 segundos
valeria saccone y luís jaldón nos
cuentan más
mi primer contacto con el skate fue
cuando tenía más o menos siete años mi
padre me regaló un skate por navidad y
una base de datos para 15 años cuando
tenía casi 15 años unos compañeros de
clase que ya andaban en skate me
invitaron a la inauguración de una pista
aquel día aprendí a tirarme de la rampa
y la sensación tuve la sensación de
haber conseguido hacer algo que parecía
muy difícil una sensación de superación
eso me llevó a desear sentir aquello
todos los días de mi vida cuando comencé
a practicar el skate estaba acabando el
instituto conseguía entrar en la
universidad federal y comencé a
frecuentar las clases pero al mismo
tiempo estaba evolucionando en el skate
amando cada vez más este deporte y
deseando pasar más tiempo encima de este
carrito bastaba este impulsión de calle
seguí mi corazón era lo que me hacía
feliz ahora defenestrado
[Música]
este es mi padre que tal papá cómo estás
este es mi profesor de yoga bruno en ese
tiempo y esté aquí es mi paraíso mi
pista que acabamos de terminar es que lo
que para el skate el hecho de estar en
unos juegos olímpicos trae un cierto
respeto en las oportunidades el apoyo y
los incentivos que no teníamos muchas
veces el skate era considerado algo
marginal marco de marginalidad
y ahora vamos a hacer unos ejercicios de
respiración un poco de meditación
[Música]
yo uso el yoga como una válvula de
escape principalmente para calmar mi
mente en el día a día durante la semana
desde aquí dibuje la pista de tokio en
la que vamos a competir en los juegos
olímpicos para poder soñar y pensar lo
que voy a hacer allá aquí en mi cuarto
imagino las líneas y las maniobras y el
hecho de ser los primeros skaters de la
historia que participan en unos juegos
olímpicos ya es algo muy especial
literalmente histórico entonces me
siento muy feliz y honrada por formar
parte de esta historia seremos para
siempre los primeros skaters que
participan en unos juegos olímpicos
más deportes
la levantadora de pesas neozelandesa lo
real hubbard de 43 años será la primera
atleta transgénero en competir en unos
juegos olímpicos después de ser
seleccionada por el equipo nacional de
su país
hubbard competirá en tokio en la
categoría femenina de 87 kilogramos y a
la parte de un total de 4 integrantes
del equipo neozelandés de halterofilia
la pesista se clasificó después de que
el comité olímpico hiciera algunos
cambios en las reglas de participación
lo que dio garantías para que javier
tuviera un lugar en la categoría de
pesos
con estas imágenes finalizamos aquí en
france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]